does someone have to die in order to be
able for us to tell our truths I think
we at least have to write as if they
have died which is that old saying right
like right as if everyone you know is
dead
um I've never heard that one before I
don't know who said it but I'm pretty
sure it's it's like a I I think it's a
saying I don't think I just coined it I
know I've never heard it before I've
definitely heard like right as if no
one's reading it or dances if nobody's
watching I mean by the way that's the
new mug being sold dog shelves I'm
actually asking honestly yeah like
do I have to wait to tell on my truths I
don't know if I can do it because
certain people are alive I understand
my thought on that is I think if saying
the truth ends a relationship I think
it's probably a relationship that needed
to end I guess